Three two,
one.
And we're live gentleman,
Doctor Neil Riordan,
my saying that right?
Yes sir.
And Mel Gibson,
how are you sir?
Hey,
how you doing?
A welcome on board folks.
First of all,
thanks for coming here.
Really appreciate it.
Very nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
So this,
uh,
you wanted to come in and talk about
stem cells.
Yeah.
So what is,
what's your experience been and what
does,
what does,
uh,
what's this calling that you have here?
Well,
I was,
uh,
initially
Chile.
It was for my dad who was,
you know,
he was 92 and uh,
and he was doing all the old man stuff,
you know,
his hip was killing him and he was like,
uh,
he had,
he had multiple problems.
I mean,
I won't get into the whole litany of
complaints,
but hey,
you know,
your engine starts wearing out,
you gotta replace the carburetor and a
few other things.
I took him to the Mayo Clinic,
great place.
If I ever get into serious trouble,
that's where I'm going.
And,
uh,
they were fantastic there,
but they were able to say,
yeah,
you got to leave me here.
It'd be dead in 48 hours.
I'm like,
oh.
So they,
they clocked every problem that he had.
Everything from,
you know,
the prostate to the,
to the hip,
to the kidneys,
to the heart,
to the lungs,
you know,
the whole deal.
And,
um,
he,
uh,
um,
you know,
they,
they stabilized him.
They said,
okay,
we'll do this and we'll do this.
And they did some,
you know,
Orthodox medical procedures all allowed
in this country.
And,
uh,
they were great.
But,
uh,
you know,
I still had reservations about him
getting a hip replacement because he was
old.
And of course,
just the recovery from a traumatic
surgery at that age is like,
it's a big deal.
And,
uh,
I thought,
well,
what can I do?
And my brother says,
why don't you look into these adult stem
cells?
I'm like,
Eh,
you know,
I've heard things about this,
you grow,
you grow a spare mouth on your head.
You ended up with an extra asshole or
something.
But I was like,
okay,
we'll look into it.
So we did.
And of course,
a buddy of mine who was a,
who was a Mayo Doc,
he said,
stay away from those witch doctors down
in Panama.
He said,
it's like a leprosy and banana boats and
three legged dogs,
you know,
and I'm like,
can we call him?
And so,
uh,
so brad and I got on the phone to Neil
and who else was it?
Doctor Pause or medical?
Yeah,
there was the two of these guys.
And um,
so they're talking highfalutin terms,
medical,
all being Medicos,
you know,
they sort of,
they know what a Mesenchymal stem cells
are.
Mesenchymal,
how do you say it misses linkable yet
you know,
and uh,
cytocon miss income,
all cytokines,
you know,
out of sight,
out of mind as far as I'm concerned.
But it's like they,
uh,
they give us the wrist watch show over
the phone for about an hour and the
doctor's asking them questions that
I can't even think of.
So when we hang up,
I said,
no,
you know,
translate.
What does all that mean?
He's like,
he translated a few things.
He says,
you know,
it sounds kind of interesting,
pretty good,
you know,
and from being a naysayer,
he said,
let's call him back.
And I think we called you right back.
And,
uh,
we spend another hour on the phone and
well to his credit,
uh,
Brad,
Brad ass for a bunch of literature.
And I sent him maybe 30 articles and
most physicians wouldn't even look at
it,
but it was all relevant to what hut had.
And,
uh,
you know,
for the heart,
the heart problems and kidney problems
and,
and orthopedic problems.
And he read all the articles and he
read,
he read the upside,
the downside,
and,
and then,
then we had a,
to his credit and then we had a,
a very educated,
uh,
talk after conversation and which he,
and he was,
he was really,
you know,
by this time informed I,
and he,
he,
he just said to me,
well,
you know,
he's 92.
He says,
what the hell you got to lose?
And I said,
no,
nothing,
let's go.
So I'm up for it.
We asked him,
is he up for it?
He goes,
hell yeah,
cause he's,
you know,
they took him into the hospital.
He was 92.
And they said,
what medications are you on?
He said,
I'm not on any.
And they said,
you're 92 years old.
How do you account for not being on any
medications?
This is because I stay away from doctors
and hospitals
and you know,
and he didn't have any problems.
He started to have have a rough trip.
Well,
uh,
we took them down there and he got,
I think it was like a double dose in the
hip.
I think you have to go,
this is not legal in America,
is that what's going on right now?
There are clinical trials going on in
the u s but it's not broadly available.
And in Panama,
they passed the law in 2004,
which allowed us,
allowed doctors actually to go down
there to be able to treat people with
using adult stem cell.
So the bill was actually designed to,
uh,
to prohibit the use of embryonic stem
cells.
And in at the same law,
they said it's okay to use adult stem
cells,
including those from a biblical cord
basically from ethical sources.
And so,
um,
in Panama they gave us a,
we have a license from the Ministry of
Health to manufacturer and use those
cells in addition to doing clinical
trials there.
So it's,
it's one place on the planet where you
can get a really high quality umbilical
cord.
These,
this type of cell,
there are two major kinds of stem cells.
We only work with one kind.
The missoulian Kamala,
we just call it the mic.
It's a lot easier.
And um,
so anyway,
that's,
that's how I think we were actually,
we actually owned apartments in the same
building in Panama.
Never met each other.
And we met,
we met through his brother finding us on
the Internet and then you go,
and then they brought him down to get
treatment.
We were,
we were quite hesitant to,
to take him,
you know,
cause the last thing you don't want is
Mel,
Mel Gibson's dad to drop down in your
clinic and he wasn't in great shape,
you know,
so he wasn't in good shape at all.
But,
uh,
you know,
as I recall when he got there,
he was in a wheelchair and really wasn't
talking a lot and things like that and
having a pretty rough time.
And,
and then,
uh,
so we,
after getting medical clearance for him
to actually fly down there and then
Melflin down there privately,
uh,
then we,
we did some ivs on him first in the
clinic and then to do the hip,
we need to do that piece.
What do you mean?
So we give the umbilical cord,
these are,
uh,
isolated from the,
the basically the,
the meat of the umbilical cord.
Uh,
they're isolated and they're grown in
our laboratory,
which is iso 9,001 and very high quality
and certified by the Ministry of Health.
Um,
the,
they're grown in the laboratory and
they're certified to be free of
everything and in any kind of infectious
disease.
And,
and,
uh,
I went into the clean rooms and then
make it put on hats and gloves and you
know,
you feel like all frankensteined out and
you'll walk into these cold rooms and
you're watching cells divided under the
microscope.
It's kind of miraculous.
Really look at this stuff.
So intravenous stem cells intravenously.
That's correct.
And what,
what's the benefit of intravenous stem
cells?
Like what does that do?
Well,
the good thing is that this,
this kind of stem cell,
the Mesenchymal stem cells are found
throughout your body.
And they're the,
normally what they do is they,
they modulate your immune system,
they decrease inflammation,
and they stimulate regeneration.
So,
and the good thing about them is they
tend to home to areas where there is
inflammation.
So intravenously,
they do a lot of things,
uh,
and,
but they can home to areas of
inflammation and uh,
and they,
they really reduce inflammation in the
body because they upregulate part of
your immune system that controls the
inflammatory process,
which I can talk more about later.
But in his case,
you know,
his kidneys were in trouble.
His heart was in trouble.
And the cells,
they don't,
unlike what we used to think in the
early days,
they don't become anything.
These kinds of,
this kind of stem cell does not become
anything in your body,
but at homestead,
areas of that need repair and it
secretes things that stimulates the
repair and decrease the inflammation and
helps out with the immune system.
So the vast majority of what we treat
our autoimmune diseases,
and uh,
in,
in [inaudible] case we gave him iv so
that,
that he could basically have these
things on board,
secreting,
secreting the cytokines and the,
and the growth factors that are normally
secreted.
And when you're 92 and you have
multiorgan failure,
you're basically running on fumes.
And so you put these days zero young,
healthy cells and they secrete these
things that kind of restarts everything.
Yeah.
And so what was his response to this Ivy
Treatment?
Wow.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I could,
I can wax lyrical about that.
He's almost a hundred years old and,
uh,
from pretty bad shape.
It was like bee stings.
It was like he got a new lease of life.
Like he got a big dose locally in the
hip,
which a fixed all his inflammation and
pain and he started walking again and
his kidneys were good and his heart,
he had a valves in there and they
healed.
And uh,
his,
um,
cognitive powers improved.
His eyesight improved.
Whoa.
You know,
and other stuff improved that I,
he would hate me to talk about it.
Two nurses that reported to me and it
was like,
holy mackerel,
using it as a towel rack.
Well,
Dan Bilzerian was telling me about
intravenous stem cells.
He's,
and so his boss route and you know,
boss,
former UFC heavyweight champion,
he went down and caught some,
he's had some pretty significant neck
injuries and neck fusions.
And he said he got intravenous stem
cells.
The way he described his,
like with his Dutch accents,
like it was like I had lightning coming
off my fingers.
Did he go to you?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He said it was phenomenal.
I mean,
he said it's one of the most incredible
experiences I've ever had.
The feeling of a regeneration of,
of energy.
Yeah.
I reach out to him by email and he,
and just to see if it'd be okay for me
to talk about him on here.
And he said,
yeah,
absolutely.
And you know,
uh,
his,
his cholesterol dropped all his numbers,
you know,
the basically numbers associated with
aging all got better.
Um,
and,
and like you said,
he felt this tremendous energy for some
period of time wise.
It's not legal here.
Well,
uh,
it,
it's considered to be a new drug by the
FDA and that's the number one reason.
There are four countries so far that
have approved MSC products.
There's Canada and New Zealand were the
first to go to Canada and get this done.
Well,
not for the,
only,
only for certain conditions.
So in Canada,
New Zealand,
they approved bone marrow mscs,
which are in my mind are not as good as
umbilical cord.
And I explain why.
Um,
and,
and then South Korea as approved
umbilical cord for knee osteoarthritis
only so the cells have to be injected
into the knee.
And then Japan just recently approved
the same product.
That's it.
It's used to treat a very serious acute
graph,
acute graft versus host disease in
children after they've had a bone marrow
transplant.
Now are there peer reviewed studies or
anything that shows the efficacy of this
intravenous use of these stem cells?
Yeah,
there,
there are hundreds.
There are hundreds and my book MSC,
which is,
you know,
you don't want to read it unless you
want to go to sleep unless you're
looking for something,
you know,
it's just,
it really is purely a research tool.
Um,
we have 800 references and we reference
every clinical trial that's ever been
done with mscs and human beings and
there are 800 of them.
Yeah.
Well I've had some great results with
stem cells.
Doctor Rati Mcgee in Las Vegas.
A shot,
a bunch into my shoulder.
I was at the door of surgery.
I was like my shoulders and pain all the
time.
I can't do a lot.
Every time I do something,
I have to ice it down for a day and now
I have full function.
I mean,
it's crazy.
I was literally,
I mean it still clicks.
I've got some weird shit in there and
there's probably
some stuff floating around in there.
But as far as like the function of my
shoulder and the,
the pain,
it's like 100% I can do basically
everything.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I was 57 58 years old and this is like
what,
four or five years ago?
And both my shoulders torn labor rooms,
arthritis,
bone spurs,
like rotator cuff issues.
And I went down and I got 10 billion
cells in each shoulder.
I said to the doc,
you know,
is this going to hurt?
And he says,
only when it comes out the other side.
But he put it in and it,
it was,
you could feel them pierce the capsule
and you could feel pressure.
And,
uh,
I couldn't flap my wings for three days,
but after that,
no more problems.
And this is different than the stem
cells that you can get in the United
States currently.
Yeah.
What's the difference
from umbilical cords?
I had a,
what is it called?
What's the kind that you can get here in
the United States?
Well,
you can use the only thing that's
legally legal in the u s at least for
now,
I don't think it's going to be last much
longer as from amnion.
Yeah,
there's an exemption in the,
uh,
it's a federal federal exemption for the
use of amnion for wound covering.
And a lot of people have now translated,
now they're using it in joints and
things like that.
But you don't think they're going to be
able to do that very much longer?
I don't believe so.
Why is that?
Cause this commissioner FDA Commissioner
has made it very clear that he doesn't
like it and they really haven't liked it
for quite some time.
Uh,
because the,
the exemption is for one thing and,
and,
and doctors are using it for all kinds
of other things.
I don't necessarily agree with it.
I just,
I just know what's coming down the pike
from a regulatory standpoint.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
there've been some regulatory things
that have come out.
They've gone after clinics and you know,
I think they've shut down three places
just in the last couple of months and
they haven't gone after amnion yet.
But I think they're building their case
for it.
And unfortunately that's what's going to
happen.
No,
why would they go after it?
That's what's confusing.
If you seen all these benefits and I
haven't heard anything about negative
results.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't understand it myself,
to be honest with you.
It's,
you know,
amnion it's been used clinically in the
United States for over a hundred years,
uh,
without serious adverse events.
But,
um,
I think it's more about the claims that
people are making because they're,
there haven't been studies,
for example,
of Amnion,
you know,
amnion tissue injected into a joint.
And I think that the biggest concern is
the claims that are being made and maybe
people are being vulnerably,
you know,
I dunno,
some vulnerable to the economics of it.
I'm not really sure,
but I know that I just,
I have my finger on the pulse and,
and that's,
it seems like they're there.
They've gone after fat.
You know,
we were the first in the world to use
fat derived stem cells in 2006 and 2007
we published in on using those to treat
rheumatoid arthritis and multiple
sclerosis a and then a lot of doctors in
the u s started doing that now.
Now there's new guidance to industry
that came out a few months ago that
specifically prohibits using it for,
for example,
taking your own fat,
isolating the stem cells out of it,
and then injecting them in your
bloodstream or even a document to a
joint.
So,
um,
it,
I,
I don't,
I don't really know the whole,
the motivation behind it,
but I know that they,
they very clearly stated that that's not
going to fly anymore.
So the stuff that you did for mel
shoulder,
what,
what exactly was that?
That's basically a new drug product.
It could be considered a new drug
product in the U S and we are in
clinical trials in the U s we've
already,
we're,
we have to imds for the treatment
additions,
muscular dystrophy,
and we're just going to start a spinal
cord injury trial.
University of Miami.
And uh,
and uh,
Thomas Jefferson University.
We got funding from the Marcus
Foundation.
Bernie Marcus is one of our clients and
he sees all these kids with spinal cord
injury getting better.
And so our product is,
we,
we were able to figure out which cells
work,
which,
which umbilical cords give cells that
are really useful and which ones aren't.
So we throw away the vast majority of
the umbilical cords that we get.
You tell.
Well,
we,
we had the advantage of having thousands
of cases and,
and I'll get,
I'll give you an example of one case of
a football coach from Dallas where I
live.
And he had diagnosed with Ms. He was in
and out of wheelchair,
was on,
you know,
basically out.
Um,
and,
uh,
he was out on disability and retired
from a very successful at three time
state champion in Texas.
That's really saying something.
Um,
and he came down in 2010 for the first
treatment and we gave him the treatment
and he got much better and improve for
about 14 months.
And then he came back again in 2011 and
got another treatment improved,
not as much as the first time.
And He came down in 2012 and boom,
all of his symptoms were gone.
And now he's back coaching and he is
completely normal.
He's probably,
you know,
he's,
he's a junior,
he's a bit younger than me,
but he's probably healthier than me.
I mean,
the guy works out all the time.
He's out there on the field.
He doesn't have any heat intolerance.
It didn't have any problems.
Uh,
so I want her to know what's the
difference between those cells in 2012
and the ones in 2011 and one of the 2010
and then we took other cases similar to
that where we'd had less than
spectacular result.
I mean there's still good results,
but they weren't,
you know,
but boom.
And so he took cells from those
different lots and we grew them up and
then we had them analyze for 1200
different molecules that they express.
And we found that these cells,
we call them our golden cells because
they,
they just seem to work all the time.
And we found that they under express
certain proteins.
And then so early on in the culture
process,
we can select for those and say,
Hey,
these are golden cells,
these aren't throw him out.
And so he throw it,
we throw a whole bunch out and we keep
the golden cells and then we grow those
up.
And those are the only cells that we
use.
So that,
that's the big,
the big difference in the advantage we
have is that we've had all those cases,
we're able to look back retrospectively
at which sells,
really work,
then analyze them from a molecular basis
and then now we can select using that.
So
when mel came in with his shoulder
injuries,
June an MRI first,
um,
he had one,
but we didn't do it there.
But he had one.
Yeah,
let's do a follow up Mri.
We did not know a lot of,
we do a lot.
It was great.
So you don't even bother.
This is good.
I don't bother.
It's like my dad was walking with that
pain,
you know,
his hip was dissolved.
He was doing okay.
Wow.
And so,
um,
are you still no problems with the
shoulder?
How long ago did you have that done?
Oh,
when was it?
I had it done twice.
It was,
I went 18 months and then I started it
started to return the symptoms of
discomfort,
pain.
And so I did it again and like,
it's been like couple of years,
almost three years.
It's fine.
Wow.
Yeah.
I was really impressed with what I was
able to get done,
but the stuff that I wish I had Dr.
McGee telling me exactly what it was,
the stuff that he,
they had done to me about a year and a
half ago is no longer available.
Um,
they decided that it was considered a
drug and uh,
they,
they weren't allowing that form of a
amniotic stem cell treatment.
So now there's a less effective but
still effective form.
Right.
So it seems like there is some sort of
an effort afoot to diminish this in the
United States.
Yeah,
well I think they just want to control
it and they want,
you know,
they want it all to go through their
deal and their process.
But in the meantime,
a lot of people are probably suffering
from some pretty significant injuries
that they could deal with,
with that far easier if this could
somehow or another be sped up.
Absolutely agree with that.
Yeah.
So when did you start doing this?
Down in Panama?
Um,
we started there in 2006 and just
because of the regulations,
right?
We found out about how about
the regulations around 2006 and,
and we went straight there and once we
found that law,
the law was passed in 2004 and then we
found out about it and we went down
there and,
uh,
we built our lab out.
We were actually functional in 2007.
So it's,
uh,
we're having our 10 year anniversary.
What's it like in Panama?
Never been a Panama.
Is it weird?
It seems like it's cool.
You like it?
Yeah.
It's cool.
Yeah,
it's very,
it's real friendly with the u s I think
that's the currency has been there as US
dollars.
Oh really?
It goes further?
Yeah.
They use US dollars.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
These US dollars.
I mean we kind of ran that joint for
many years until 1999 when they would
gave the canal back and that was pretty
much the vast majority of the economy.
So when we gave that back to them then
they just kept the dollar.
And uh,
it's been,
you know,
the explosive growth,
it looks like Miami now.
So,
you know,
my bill at the building I live in is 70
stories tall and it's not even the
building,
you know.
So there's,
there are,
our clinic is on the 63rd floor of a 65
story building and it just full of high
rises.
And of course there's a little bit too
much traffic if you get that much
concentration of people in one place.
But,
um,
fantastic restaurants,
movie theaters,
mall shopping,
high end shopping malls,
you name it,
you got everything that you want down
there.
And you know,
I'd love to spend time,
I spend a third of my time down there.
It's friendly and it's relative,
you know,
it's not dangerous.
Wow.
So you have people that you,
that hear about you from the United
States and they find out about your,
your treatment and then fly down to
Panama to get treated.
Yeah,
that's right.
Not just the u s but probably the
majority of the clients are from the u s
and then we'd have people from all other
places around the globe.
Do you anticipate this moon back to the
United States in any way or is this
something that the hurdles are so steep
that it's going to take a long time?
I think we're going to figure out a way
to do it.
You know,
I think ultimately we're going to do it.
Um,
we're,
you know,
just having,
we were the first to get an eye to treat
a human being in the United States with
these cells.
And,
uh,
that was three and a half years ago with
the young man with the shins,
muscular dystrophy.
And My,
you know,
my other book that's hopefully
interesting to read.
It starts and finishes with his case
where,
um,
we were,
we traded him in Panama for a number of
years and then we just petitioned the
FDA and said,
it's kind of ridiculous for us to do
this down there.
Please allow us to do it.
So we're using the cells that we,
we isolated and uh,
expanded in Panama.
We're using it to treat him and another,
uh,
now a seven year old with Duchenne's
muscular dystrophy.
So that was the first wedge.
And then our next wedge is going to be
for spinal cord injury.
And uh,
there,
there a number of clinical trials that
are going on,
not,
not just outside the u s are a number of
going on in the u s the biggest hurdle
is that a new drug,
if you look at the last several years,
cost two and a half billion dollars to
get to market.
And,
uh,
unless we do something a little bit
differently on the regulatory side,
it's going to be,
it's gonna be Kinda hard to do this.
Japan has a law that went into effect
two years ago that basically allows you,
allows you to,
once you demonstrate your product is
safe,
then you can go ahead and start
marketing it and then you have seven
years in which to,
to demonstrate efficacy.
So safety first,
then efficacy,
and that's resulted in four,
four new drugs already and in less than
two years.
And uh,
we have zero zero cell,
the only sell product that's,
that's approved by FDA as umbilical cord
blood for the treatment of,
uh,
when you're doing a bone marrow
transplant,
that's the only thing that's approved.
Now is there an argument for that?
Like they just being cautious,
they want to make sure that there's no
adverse side effects that could really
be significant.
Yeah,
I think there is an argument there.
There's an argument that they want it.
They want to err on the side of safety.
I mean that's their number one priority
is to,
is to create,
uh,
create a safe environment for receiving
medicines in the,
in the United States.
Um,
I,
I think the model is a little bit,
there's a little bit antiquated for the
cell products just because they are
natural products.
I mean,
if you think about it,
uh,
every woman that's ever given birth to a
baby,
they have stem cells from their baby in
them.
These MSC is,
you can find them 50 years later and
they're not toxic.
And we wouldn't exist as a species if
there is a inherent toxicity to a
genetically distinct cells because the
cells are 50% mom,
50% dad and there you can find them in
mom,
you know,
for her entire life.
Um,
so the,
and the cures act was supposed to,
we're supposed to address some of that
and we'll see that that went into effect
last year and we'll see,
uh,
going forward if that actually does
affect things.
Now I know that they're doing some stuff
in the United States where they're
injecting them into disks.
This is a new thing to regenerate disc
tissue for people that have degenerative
disc disease and bulging discs and disc
injuries and a,
as an alternative to either artificial
discs or fusion as a first step before
they move into those.
Do you do any of that down there?
Um,
we don't do any right now.
Uh,
we're,
we're working with a hospital that
we're actually going to,
we're going to have a room just for
doing backs,
just,
just for doing spine because there are
study that has study out of Europe.
Just came out a couple of months ago and
it showed about 50% of the patients had
their disks become normal on Mri after
treatment.
So it's not every case,
but I would,
I'd take a 50,
50 shot versus having a,
having a fusion.
Right.
Yeah.
So that's the same sort of situation
that we're talking about where you're
injecting it right into the desks.
Yeah.
And you can,
in the United States,
you know,
we have a clinic in Dallas,
uh,
that the RMI clinic where we,
we can do bone marrow,
right.
And,
and so we use bone,
autologous bone marrow,
and we do do disc in the United States.
And it does help a percentage of people
doesn't help everybody.
And like we were talking before about
not just not just the desk but the
muscles around the desk.
So if you take somebody who's had an
injury,
um,
my partner,
Dr Mckenna is a orthopedic surgeon and
he's been talking about this for years.
But if you take somebody with a disc
injury and you look at the muscles right
on either side of the spine there and
you'll find that they're withered away
or they're marbled with fat and that,
that sort of thing,
you take an elite athlete,
so it's super healthy,
works out all the time.
Those muscles,
they're like,
they're like ropes.
That's a full light Manyana the human
body,
right?
And you look at that and they're just
black on Mri,
but you take somebody that's had a disc
injury at any level and you can look and
there's marbling in there and it's
withered and that sort of thing.
So,
uh,
one of the things we do in South Lake in
Dallas is we inject the desk but also
inject those muscles along the side.
And that's using your own bone marrow.
And that's still allowed in the United
States.
So the bone marrow draw the concentrate,
the stem cells inject him in those
areas.
Well,
that's something that we were talking
about earlier when I showed you the
reverse hyper when I showed you that
machine and then that,
that Dex back stretcher.
I think that's a significant part of the
injuries that you see with people with
discs,
with back injuries.
They don't have strong backs right
there.
The tissue,
the muscle around the back that protects
the spine.
It's just very weak.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's fantastic machine.
I'm going to get one.
Yeah,
you got to get one or two mil.
I've got a crazy back dude.
That picture you showed me your back is
fucking banana.
Yeah,
no,
it's like out of a nursery rhyme.
Hey,
is that what I had done down in Texas
with the bone marrow?
Mel Actually had that done yet in Texas.
Yeah.
How many treatments have you had
while there was that one?
And then I had the shoulders twice and
then I just had him drop it into my
vein,
you know,
just run around.
What's that like?
It's pretty cool.
I mean,
you feel a little sleepy for a couple of
days and then you feel pretty energetic,
really sleepy.
Yeah.
It kind of,
I think it takes its toll on you.
I mean,
um,
I don't know why you feel sleepy.
Neil may have an explanation for that,
but yeah,
well like two,
three days where the cells are good,
they kind of reeducate the immune
system,
you know,
like a lot of what we treat our
rheumatory right.
Artists and multiple sclerosis,
autoimmune diseases,
and there's a retraining that's going on
in the immune system.
And um,
so that,
that involves cytokines and those,
those molecules,
those peptides are the things that make
you feel sick.
I mean,
when you get the flu,
the flu virus doesn't make you sick.
It's your body's immune reaction to
that.
That's the stuff that's being thrown off
from the,
from the fight.
That's what actually makes you feel
sick.
And so when you're activating certain
things,
parts of the immune system and they're
throwing off things can make you a
little bit tired.
Some people,
very small percentage have some flu like
symptoms for one day,
but those are,
that's kind of like the extent of the
side effects that we typically see.
But if you,
if you look at like you ask why hasn't
been being done us,
um,
for,
for rheumatic drugs.
So you,
you see them on TV,
um,
they're advertised basically every hour
of every day on almost every station and
you see these antirheumatics and you
know,
if you have rheumatoid arthritis,
if you have psoriatic arthritis or this
sort of thing,
um,
these are biologics and these are
antibodies to a certain molecule called
TNF.
TNF is one of the commanders of the
immune system.
It kind of,
it says,
Hey,
let's,
let's cause a bunch of inflammation and
make you miserable.
And so the,
the,
these drugs basically bind up or sop up
the TNF that's in your body for a period
of time.
That's why you have to get retreated
like every month,
every six months,
every two months.
Something like that,
six weeks,
two months,
and you have to get retrained and
retreated.
Um,
there's a study of rheumatoid arthritis
where they,
it was 172 people that were already on,
on medication for the rheumatoid
arthritis,
not adequately controlled.
They gave him like the equivalent of
what a typical we give him.
Panama is like roughly 120 million cells
and all of them got better.
All of them symptomatically improved.
And,
and the cool thing was that that tnf
Alpha and another molecule similar,
similar to it,
decreased by 50% and that decreased
persisted for eight and a half months
that was linked to the study.
So rather than putting an antibody in
two to sop up what's being produced,
apparently by your immune system,
you,
the cells tell your immune system to
stop it,
right.
The cells,
they up a certain immune cell called the
t regulatory cell that says to the
immune system,
hey,
quit making tnf alpha.
Queet quit making this [inaudible]
stuff.
And they took 30 patients,
a sub cohort like three months later and
gave him another shot,
the same dose and it dropped their
levels,
another 50% from that baseline.
So from,
from baseline to post second treatment,
two treatments to ib,
sitting in a chair,
uh,
dropped their levels,
75%.
It just seems like something that would
be amazing for overall repair.
Like just go down there and let your
body just get a little dose of healing
to figure out what the fuck is wrong
with them.
We'll talk about like we talked about
something and Costa Rica,
we were both there and um,
I had uh,
uh,
you know,
they looked at my neck,
I had a 50% occlusion in the right
carotid,
you know,
like build up of stuff.
Like,
like you don't feel it happening all of
a sudden,
you know,
all of a sudden when your carotids is
shut down,
they think,
well,
you have to eat the statens,
right?
Yeah.
Like crystal or lipitor and you know,
I looked at what the side effects of
those things are.
Yeah.
And I said,
I'd rather die than eat those things.
And they said,
well,
you,
and they try and make you feel guilty
for not doing it.
You got kids,
you got,
you know,
like,
eh,
but it's a,
um,
uh,
I don't have that stuff now and I didn't
get anyone to go in and remove it.
And I don't know if I can attribute that
to the cells,
but I got a bunch of cells like twice
and that went away.
Now I talk about that for a minute.
Does that sort of a,
yeah.
Well,
just in,
in general,
your,
your body,
you have a certain number of these cells
when you're born and they age just like
the rest of your body.
And they,
they,
they perform more poorly as you age,
right?
So if you take one of these cells from a
newborn,
like when you were born,
you could pluck one of these cells out,
throw it in a petri dish and let it
grow.
You let it grow for a month.
It divides roughly every 24 hours or
that's the doubling rate.
So at the end of a month you have a
billion cells and then at at,
if you take from a 35 year old and do
the same thing,
it's doubling times like two days
instead of one day.
And at the end of the month you have
32,000 cells and you take them from a 65
year old who's relatively healthy and
they divide every 60 hours.
You get 200 cells at the end of the
month.
So if your problem is a thousand cells
or it's 20,000 cells or if it's a
million cells,
you can't get it done at past a certain
age.
Just because it sells don't have the
regenerative capacity.
And the good thing about the umbilical
cord cells is they,
if you co culture them with these older
people cells with the young cells,
they don't even have to touch each
other.
Just the secretions of the young cells
will make the young,
the old cells start dividing faster and
behaving younger and the Mitochondria to
see pictures.
And in my book you can see a picture of
of cells from a 65 year old diabetic and
without any,
without any juice on them.
And then you put the juice from the
young cells on there and they look like
18 year old mscs with,
with the functional Mitochondria,
Mitochondria all throughout the cell
body rather than all bunched up.
They have,
they look health.
They just,
I mean as a cell biologist,
I know what looks healthy and anybody
else would you,
you can see just from the picture how
vastly different it is just to be
exposed to the,
to the juice.
You know,
you,
you said heard of this pair of biosis
study they did at Harvard where they
took young minds and young minds and
they,
and they sewed them together with old
mice and then the old mice actually got
younger and use the blood of the young
mice and put it in the old mice.
Well they literally sewed them together
so their bodies together so their bodies
together and so their bloodstreams
together.
Oh Geez.
That the bloodstream is mixing and so
that the young Frankenstein Shit.
Yes,
Pretty Frankie.
But they,
uh,
so at the end,
at the end of the study,
they showed that,
um,
that,
that the older,
the older mice got,
their neurologic system got better,
the cardiovascular system got better,
skeletal muscle got better,
everything got better.
And,
and one of the key molecules in there,
um,
is called GDF 11 and GDF 11 is if we,
when we look at the secret home,
that's what the cells secrete when
they're growing.
And we pull that out and we quantify it
in the top four every time as GDF 11
from the golden cells.
So the golden cells or,
or producing GDF 11,
which is one of the key molecules for
stimulating regeneration in your body.
So what other auto immune diseases do
you think could be assisted by this?
Well,
um,
we,
we do a lot of Ms. Um,
that's probably our number one
indication.
We just finished a clinical trial,
prospective clinical trial we submitted
for publication.
It should be,
it should be coming out in the next
month or so.
Um,
and,
and statistically,
significantly the,
they,
these patients improved dramatically.
And as far as side effect profile is,
it was highly minimal and me feel
headaches and phew,
phew,
flu like symptoms,
things like that.
But this was what 20 people and one of
the,
one of the individuals actually is
clinically is perfect and all of his
legions went away and we only did one
treatment with these.
Typically with Ms,
it's more refractory then rheumatory
arthritis,
rheumatoid arthritis.
Usually after one treatment people get a
ton of benefit with Ms. They usually see
after two or three treatments that they,
they really,
they see the most benefit.
And we only did one treatment in this,
in this trial,
but one,
one gentleman had three lesions in his
brain.
All three legions completely
disappeared.
So,
um,
ms is a big thing.
Rheumatory arthritis is a big thing and
I could tell you their stories in the,
not stories,
but you know,
people talking about their responses and
it's pretty incredible.
There's one lady that,
um,
her husband was a physics phd physicist.
He carried on working just so she could
afford,
just so she could have insurance to
afford the medications,
which are around a hundred grand a year
for her to get treated for rheumatoid
arthritis.
And she came down about,
it'll be,
it's a little over three years ago,
November.
And she hasn't been on any medications
since.
She actually started walking around the
mall when she was in Panama.
And then when she got home,
she's completely pain free and she,
she'd been pain free for three years and
her husband finally retired because he
didn't care about,
you know,
having the insurance to pay for these
very expensive drugs that she was taken.
So,
Ms Rheumatoid Arthritis,
Lupus,
um,
we don't,
we don't have a lupus protocol.
There's,
there's a,
a group in China that's,
that's published six really good papers
on Lupus and it's very,
very effective in their trials.
We haven't done that yet.
Um,
and,
and then autism,
it's not considered an autoimmune
disease,
but,
um,
we,
we have a trial.
We just completed our autism trial with
33 33,
uh,
enrollees,
with very good results.
Uh,
many,
many of those kids became not autistic
after treatment.
Um,
confusing to me because you talked about
people that are young,
right?
So why,
why would it have such a benefit,
benefit for them?
Well,
um,
I wrote an article in 2007 about why
these cells should be good for autism
and,
and basically it,
um,
it's,
and it's the most downloaded article
this journal's ever had.
Something like 75,000 people have
downloaded a scientific journal article,
which really doesn't happen very often.
Um,
but kids,
people with autism have inflammatory
things going on in their body a lot of
times in the gut.
Um,
there are in the,
in the,
at the end of the small intestine,
there are these inflammatory nodules
that look a lot like Crohn's disease and
they secrete these,
this inflammation,
the thing goes to the brain and planes,
the white matter of the brain,
the white matter of brain swells,
decreases the blood flow to the brain.
All of that's,
you know,
intertwined.
And then just a few years ago,
there was this study that came out and
this is what,
this is what allowed us to go forward
with our clinical trial.
Um,
they found that there the two
inflammatory molecules that are MDC and
torque and they're perfectly correlate
with the severity of symptoms of autism.
And so we measured not only those two
but another 30 some biomarkers we
measure.
We did quantitative eeg is we did a lot
of standardized scoring store a scoring
with a neurologist that,
that read them,
you know,
before treatment,
during treatment,
after treatment.
Uh,
so I,
I believe a lot of the problems with
autism,
half stem from the inflammatory status
and these cells are definitely anti
inflammatory.
Yeah.
They've had some benefit,
uh,
with changing the Diet and changing the
gut biome of kids with autism and
they've made some benefits of that and
which they believe is also connected to
inflammation.
Yeah,
absolutely.
If your,
if your immune system's freaking out,
every time you eat a piece of bread,
uh,
and that,
and that immune system is thrown out
molecules that are swollen your brain
and inflaming your brain,
then it makes complete sense.
And Yeah.
You know,
I think in general that the people with
autism that do the best are the ones
that get that addressed before they come
down.
Um,
you know,
there's some other doctors that do
functional medicine and they look at
their diet,
they look at,
see if they have any heavy metals and
that sort of thing.
And the ones that just are slam dunk,
do the best.
I've been cleaned up before they come
down.
Well,
so what about heart disease?
You were saying you were talking about
people that have heart issues.
Yeah.
Uh,
we have a number of patients with heart
failure that have responded quite well.
Failure,
heart failure,
heart attack,
need of a transplant,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
On transplant lists and that sort of
thing.
Yeah.
I have a friend who's on a transplant
list.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
um,
there are different kinds of heart
failure and um,
so,
but uh,
the other thing interesting about heart
failure's a cells don't need to go to
the heart and to actually become new
heart cells and that sort of thing.
It's actually the secretions of the
cells.
Like I said before,
there was,
there was a study at University of
Buffalo where they took,
they injected cells ivy in a,
in a hamster model of heart failure.
And,
and then they looked in the,
in the heart and there were very few
cells,
but the heart failure got better.
And then they said,
oh,
let's inject,
let's inject those same cells.
These are MSC umbilical mncs inject them
into the,
into the hamstring muscle.
And they demonstrated that none of the
cells came out of the hamstring muscle
and yet the heart failure app better.
So then they took just the juice,
the liquid that the cells secrete and
they start,
stay simulated.
The amount of juice that the cells would
have produced in the body and just
injected the Jews and the heart failure
at better.
So it's really the secretions of the
cells stimulating the natural repair,
augmenting the natural repair process of
the body that has been stretched to its
limit.
You know,
if you have a 65 year old,
those cells aren't dividing very well.
This,
the Jews can help the cells divide
faster and produce more repair molecules
and,
and make it better.
So do you think that it could take
someone who's on a heart transplant list
and literally fix their heart?
I've seen it happen time and again.
Wow.
And there,
there,
there are clinical trials using similar
cell types that also have demonstrated
that,
you know,
there's a,
there's a molecule called BMP,
which is high and heart failure.
The BNP came down in every single case,
uh,
the injection ejection fraction,
which measures kind of like the
efficiency,
how much,
how much blood you're heart's pumping on
each stroke.
Uh,
went up.
And every single patient,
you know,
I think are in the book.
The,
the craziest case was a,
was a Gringo who was down in Costa Rica
and,
and he,
he,
he was our,
I don't know,
he was probably 20,
25% routinely,
but he got a viral disease or something
else and he was 11% ejection fraction,
normals about 60.
And uh,
they,
the,
the regular,
the regular hospital who worked a lot
with us using with our spinal cord
patients and seeing results,
seeing people walking again,
um,
they,
they just said,
you can't get on a plane.
You're at 3,700 feet.
If you get on a plane,
you'll be dead.
You might as well go see these guys over
at stem cell place and see if anything
had happened.
And I think his case is in the book as
well.
But he went from,
I dunno,
11 to 42 or something like that.
Um,
that he wasn't the first case.
The first case was a doctor who's a
friend of George's friend,
doctor pause or medical director,
um,
who had congenital.
So his,
his mother had died of heart failure.
His sister had died,
his brother had died and he was,
you know,
not even 50 years old and his ejection
fraction was hovering around 30%.
And a lot of people at,
you know,
at an advanced age,
you're not even going to get on the
list.
Cause if you,
if you're a,
if you're a 50 or 60 year old and
there's a 20 year old ahead of Ya,
20 year old's going to win.
And so he begged and begged to come
down.
He was our first patient and we didn't
even really want to take him because we
didn't know what was gonna happen cause
nobody had ever done it.
And we treated him and he went back.
Um,
and he had his,
he had an ejection fraction,
you know,
the echocardiogram and it was 52% and
then the doctor didn't believe it.
So he did read it.
It a month later it was 55%.
So,
um,
I,
you know,
it's not,
I don't think it's for every case and we
have people with like a super bad heart
attack and there's not enough to repair
and you really need a heart transplant.
But I think,
I think you're going to see that it's
ultimately I think in 20 years are
probably going to see standard of care
for diseases,
chronic diseases like any chronic
degenerative disease for which there's
no good treatment.
You're going to see standard of care is
going to be young,
healthy mesenchymal stem cells.
Because if you look at the root cause
here I get a question a lot.
How was it?
How is it these things worked for so
many things.
Well when the root cause is a lack of or
dysfunction of those cells,
then it makes sense that replenishing
those are re restoring them with young
healthy wounds could be a useful
treatment.
Well Mel,
this is so important to you that you
wanted to come on and talk about this.
He wanted to let people know about this
shit.
Yeah,
I think it's amazing.
And,
and it seems a crime to me that,
you know,
it isn't easier to do in this country
where,
you know,
we're,
we're an advanced country.
I mean,
they should look a little harder at it
and it's a
mystery to me why it isn't the case.
But,
you know,
hey,
uh,
if there are places where one can go and
get some help,
it's good.
I mean,
I know another Gal,
she's a good friend of mine,
she tour a shoulders up because she was
like an athlete and,
uh,
she had her shoulders down and she got
some dropped into her and it actually,
uh,
helped greatly with an autoimmune
disorder that she had.
And then she was able to have kids.
It was that kind of thing,
you know?
Yeah.
There,
there,
there's some really good animal data
showing that you can inject these cells
and you can take ovarian failure and
reverse it.
And in her case,
she,
uh,
she had an autoimmune disease and she
was unable to have children told that
from the very young age.
And,
um,
after treatment she got pregnant pretty
quickly.
This sounds almost too good to be true.
This is almost like be skeptical.
People that are listening to this right
now.
I'll probably be like,
why this fucking shit cures everything.
It sounds like the old spruik around the
corner.
Good for moles,
holes and pimples on ones.
But you've got studies.
You mean you've got real trials to back
this up and you've got a host of
patients that are healed up and,
and,
and healthy.
Uh,
yeah,
totally sound.
Take nothing wrong with me.
I want to go down there and shut up.
You see a 92 year old man who is about
ready to kick the bucket and he's almost
a hundred.
He's going to celebrate 100 years in
August.
So,
and it's incredible.
He's,
he's better off than he was.
Let me tell you.
Yeah.
This young guy with,
uh,
the shins,
muscular dystrophy,
you know this,
the cells don't last forever.
This is also an important point.
Uh,
with the shins,
it's,
it's a,
it's a genetic defect.
So they're missing a protein and these
cells go in this,
in animal models,
he sells,
you give them to the animal.
They go into the muscle and then they,
they start secreting that molecule that
they're missing but they only last for
about four or five,
six months.
And then they,
then they start maturing and then the
immune system clears them.
It's a real important point.
You don't have that with embryonic stem
cells because they cause tumors and
things like that.
And the great thing about these cells,
they don't cause tumors because they
differentiate.
They don't want to be a baby.
They are just there to do their job,
which is to keep homeostasis,
keep,
keep the immune system controlled.
Can you know,
help with regeneration,
all that sort of thing.
But the embryonic stuff,
cause I find this interesting,
the embryonic step is full of weird
anomalies and stuff.
Yeah.
We wrote,
a few of us got together and wrote an
article when they finally put the clamp
on the last embryonic stem cell
treatment and we'd been saying for years
that embryonic stem cells aren't going
to work because they want to become
babies.
Their number one problem is they want to
become babies.
They don't want to these cells,
the cells that we start with,
they don't want to become babies.
The babies are already born.
These are,
they're mature,
they're Mesenchymal,
and,
and that's what they are and that
they're never going to be anything else.
Um,
whereas the embryonic stem cells,
um,
the biggest problem with them is they
always form tumors.
They form teratomas.
And so in order for them to be
functional,
you have to grow them out.
And if you want them to have MSC,
like qualities,
you have to force them to become mscs.
And then you have to make darn sure that
there aren't any,
if I only takes one,
if there's one left,
then it's going to form a tumor.
So that was the big problem that the
expense,
and it was three,
$400,000 a dose just to make sure that
they didn't have one in them.
And then they weren't as beneficial.
And they'd been monkeyed with in the lab
from when they were embryonic and then
converted and converted and converted
and converted and then grown up in huge
numbers.
And so they were monkeyed with these
cells.
You don't have to monkey with it.
And they just do it naturally.
You just take them out,
you digest them,
you put,
you put them in a nutrient broth and the
right temperature and humidity and
oxygen levels,
and they just grow.
And so,
um,
the,
you know,
we wrote an article about embryonic stem
cells.
We call it the king is the king is dead
long live the king because,
you know,
the,
the California,
the California voters kneejerk $3
billion towards an embryonic stem cell
work,
uh,
you know,
against the Bush administration's
restriction of spending money on
embryonic stem cell research,
it wasn't banned,
as most people said.
All they said was,
we're not going to use taxpayer money,
federal taxpayer money to go towards
that.
And what people heard was they don't
want,
they don't want progress.
Well,
what's happened is they,
at last count,
I think they spent,
you know,
two,
two and three quarter billion dollars.
They've got $250 million left.
And guess what they're studying now,
adult stem cells,
they're studying umbilical cord stem
cells.
They're studying Mesenchymal stem cells,
they've completely cut out everything on
the embryonic side because it just took
that long.
There was so much misinformation out
there.
Um,
and,
and now thank God it's gone and,
and we regain our sanity,
but we blew it.
We blew a lot of dough on a,
on the whole embryonic thing.
Yeah.
It was a lot of money.
And we paid as taxpayers in California
for that,
you know,
cause people were misinformed.
So if a person's listening to you right
now and they've got some issues,
what's the first step they should take?
Well,
um,
I say guys got a blown knee and is
thinking about getting surgery.
Yeah.
Well they could go in,
our website is sell medicines,
cll,
medicine.com for Panama.
If you know,
if there's,
if it's something that can be addressed
with bone marrow in the u s RMI
clinic.com.
That's our,
uh,
the bone marrow's just not as effective.
Well,
it,
it can be.
It,
it's,
it's hard to say because everybody's
bone marrow is different.
Your age is different.
You know,
if you're 85 years old,
even if you're 65 years old and you're a
smoker or you're diabetic,
I don't think it's worth typically using
your bone marrow because it's just not
going to do a lot.
Uh,
but younger,
younger people,
healthier people,
a lot of times you can,
you know,
when it's in a joint,
because that's the only thing we can do
in the u s is orthopedics,
so.
Right.
But if it's an orthopedic problem,
then you know,
they could check out,
see it,
see if they could,
you know,
we could do something for him in Dallas.
If it's not orthopedic and you need
systemic treatment for autoimmune
disease.
If you have a spinal cord injury,
uh,
or autism,
any of those conditions,
then they go to sell medicine,
cll,
medicine.com and that's where we have,
um,
there's all the information there and
they can fill out an application and
doctors get back with them and getting
in the system.
Now,
how difficult is it to go down to Panama
and get treatment?
Like how do you schedule that?
Well,
that's,
that's all taken care of.
There's a whole team of people that do
that.
Um,
the only thing is you need a passport
and uh,
there's no visa required anything like,
uh,
from la it's six hours way Far East.
So it's like,
it's like going to Miami.
It's like two hours.
Yeah.
It's actually two little over two hours
from Miami.
Uh,
so cause it's cause it's waste,
it's almost due south of Atlanta.
It's closer to New York,
right?
Yeah.
It's five,
five,
four,
four and a half,
five New York,
probably something like that.
So sell medicine.com they go there,
contact you.
Now,
do they need to have some sort of a
consultation with a local doctor or an
MRI or anything like that before they go
to see you?
Oh yeah.
There they need to have a diagnosis from
a physician for what they have.
And then you know that we have a team of
doctors there and they'll talk to them
and see what they need.
If they need any other information than
any other,
you know,
x rays or MRI's or whatever that
they'll,
they'll sort all that out.
This is all fascinating stuff,
man.
And I never thought about going to
Panama until about an hour ago.
Now I'm thinking of taking a trip.
Yeah.
It's worth it.
I just want to feel the intravenous
stuff.
I want to feel what boss Ruben was
talking about.
The lightening bolts coming off my
fingers.
He's a little dramatic.
Yeah.
Well he's definitely dramatic.
I wouldn't say that to his face
with a smile only.
But yeah,
he's uh,
when you treated him,
he was going through some pretty
significant issues with his neck.
Yup.
What benefits did he find off of that?
Well,
you know,
I don't think for his neck,
it structurally,
we weren't able to get the cells there.
And I don't know if there's enough
laughed,
you know,
it's a lot of people.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's nothing,
if there's nothing structurally to,
you know,
to do anything.
But a lot of people talk about,
you know,
hair loss and these cells,
burke for hair loss and yeah,
they do pretty good job,
but you can't grow,
you can't grow grass on concrete,
you know,
and you can't,
you can't stimulate a nerve to regrow
that tea.
There's no,
not even a thread left.
So he,
he didn't get,
I don't believe you got any benefit from
his as accident problem,
but he,
you know,
the,
the metabolic benefits were fantastic
for him and,
and energy wise and things like that.
His,
one of,
one of his issues is that he has some
atrophy on one of his arms because his
nerves in his neck were being pinched
and for a long time and he didn't
address it quick enough and,
uh,
it got to the point where his arm is
shrinking.
Right.
And that's one of the reasons why I went
down there.
Did he experience any benefit from that?
I don't believe he did.
No,
no.
That's a tough one,
right?
Regeneration of nerves,
especially really long time.
Uh,
you know,
for,
for like for spinal cord injury,
um,
we did,
uh,
we did a cohort analysis and,
and basically if,
if they're within one year of injury,
100% of 100% of the patients ree ree had
restoration of some neurologic function.
It was between one and two years is 82%.
It was after two years.
It was 50% so the longer it is and the,
and also the older you are,
the less you have less.
You know the reason these cells work for
spinal cord injuries,
they don't become spa,
they don't become nerves or anything
like that.
But uh,
the spinal cord is one of the most
replete,
uh,
areas of the body when it comes to blood
vessels.
They're very,
they're just barely enough blood vessels
to keep it alive.
And your liver on the other hand has
just tons of blood vessels in it.
And your liver,
you can cut 80% of your liver out and it
will regrow itself with your spinal
cord.
You just kind of digging a little bit
and it won't repair itself.
That's because there are no blood
vessels and therefore there are no msc
or very few mscs.
So like one 50th the number of mscs
reside in your spinal cord because we
built this wonderful cage around it to
protect it.
And so all we're doing is we,
we shoot the cells in there,
we also give them a,
My v and the cells secrete the things
that are necessary for this,
for the spinal cord to regenerate
itself.
But the longer it is from inner jury,
the more scarring there is and all that
sort of thing.
Uh,
the less benefit you're going to see.
So do you anticipate a time where
there'll be able to regenerate spinal
tissue or someone has got a spinal cord
injury where they have partial or some
sort of paralysis and they can be able
to regenerate?
That?
I do and I,
and we have many cases that it's already
happened.
Really?
Yeah.
Like what cases?
Well,
you know Juan Carlos Maria is a
commercial pilot from,
from Costa Rica and he was one day
flying is a,
a national geographic photographer
around and then his private plane and
they pancake and both of them got spinal
cord injuries and JC say pancakes.
You mean crashed,
crashed the plane yet?
Yeah,
they were up on a volcano and it's like
some crazy winds and stuff and it just,
it just dropped out of the sky and
landed on the ground.
Um,
and,
and he had,
he had,
uh,
no,
no function and no,
uh,
no sensation below the injury,
basically from his belly button down,
had no erectile function,
no bowel function by function,
any of that stuff.
And you know,
the first time we treated him,
um,
and how are you treating them?
We're giving them ib cells and
interfaith intrathecal,
so into the spinal fluid.
So the first,
the first round of treatments,
uh,
after that,
his,
his biggest,
he had,
he described it as like a 10 out of a 10
pain scale.
So we had this neuropathic pain that was
just like,
he was shoveling down narcotics like
nobody's business.
And He,
after the first treatment he didn't get
any restoration of function or,
but his pain dropped from a 10 to a
three.
And so he got off the narcotics.
Then the second time we treated him,
he got his left leg back and he could
move it.
And how long after the treatment?
Um,
okay.
We started treating him six months and
three days after his accident.
And then,
so he got the,
the first round of treatments was in,
you know,
the first month and it was about three
months later.
We did the second round,
but three months later he got his right
leg back and then three months later,
it was over about a year at 15 month
period probably in total.
He basically got everything back.
He got erectile function,
he got bowel,
bladder,
all that sort of thing.
And you know,
I just,
I just had dinner with him the other
night and Costa Rica and he can walk in
here and he got his commercial pilot's
license back and you know,
he started a new business and you know,
he has,
he's 100%,
he's,
I wouldn't say 100% because he does have
a bit of a limp,
but he broke his leg when he was four
wheeling.
So a maniac.
Yeah,
he can't get enough.
This is this before or after the
accident?
They broken.
No.
So yeah.
So he got all better and he was
perfectly fine.
And then he goes out and four wheeling
and breaks his leg.
So yeah,
so he was 100% then he fucked himself up
again.
So he lifts a little bit.
But,
but most people don't know that he ever
had a spinal cord injury,
you know?
That's incredible.
So you feel like with conventional
treatment that guy would still be in a
wheelchair?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean he was the,
he made zero progress so that when we
were designing this study that we're
doing at Miami that's being funded by
the Marcus people,
um,
there are two newer neurosurgeons that
are on that.
So we wanted to,
okay,
we're discussing what at what,
at what time,
point you,
we accept him and these,
these very prominent neurosurgeon said,
let's do six months because at six
months you got 98 to 99% back.
Everything you're going to have.
So let's do patients or subjects that
are from six months to two years.
And so that's the,
those are the inclusion criteria.
That's a timing that we're going to do
for the study.
At Miami.
This is phenomenal.
So is that study published online?
Is there anything where,
or this case rather publish on cases,
posts online?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's referencing my book.
It's on,
yeah,
what's referenced in both books but uh,
in the spinal cord chapter.
Um,
so stem cell therapy rising tide is the
one that it's written for the lay
person.
Um,
that,
that it,
so it's referenced in there and the
whole story about Juan Carlos and his,
you know,
his journey and how he got started and
everything's in there as well as a
reference to the published article that
in a scientific journal about his case.
And then MSC is the one that you read if
you want to go to sleep or if you're a
super nerd.
Exactly,
exactly.
And sell medicine.com that's the,
that's the website.
Yep.
CLL medicine.com.
Well,
listen,
man,
this is fantastic stuff.
And uh,
I mean I'm very intrigued and I really
a,
I hope people that have issues can reach
out to you and a,
and try to see if you can get some
treatment.
And if a,
I would love to hear back from them.
I mean,
what,
what happened with you and what happened
with your dad?
It's just incredible.
And the stuff that I've experienced in
the United States seems like it's not
nearly as potent as the stuff that
you're using down there.
And I've had some pretty dramatic
results.
Yeah.
So it's incredible stuff.
Cool.
Pete?
TJ dillashaw says hi.
Oh,
you know Tj?
Yeah.
He came down there and Daddy,
yeah,
I came down here like three months
before the last fight and then he got
his belt back and he's really done.
Well,
he,
he told me,
I could tell you everything.
He got ibs and he got his shoulder done
cause he was,
his shoulder was really bothering them.
So that was,
that was it.
And then he,
uh,
and he went down to Panama to get all
that done.
Yep.
How'd you find out about him or how did
he find out?
Rather frankly,
I don't know,
uh,
maybe boss or somebody else in that.
We've had a few MMA guys and I asked him
in Baas Baas and he both said that is
okay to talk about it.
I'm going down there.
Yeah.
Well,
listen,
man,
uh,
Israel treat real pleasure.
I'm so fascinated about this stuff
because of my own personal experience
with the,
you know,
the,
the limited amount of a stem cell
treatments that I've gotten,
but I've had great results.
I had a knee injury that was bothering
me forever.
I don't feel it at all anymore.
Uh,
the shoulder,
it doesn't bother me at all anymore.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it's pretty amazing stuff.
And from what you're saying,
I'm getting a very watered down,
not nearly as potent version of what you
have in Panama.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
So a cell medicine.com.
Yes,
sir.
And then the books again,
our MSC,
say that word again.
Mesil Mesenchymal stem cells,
stem cells and stem cell therapy arising
tide.
Mel Gibson.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
This man in here.
Appreciate it.
All right,
fuckers.
Read it.
Look it up.
Get healthy.
Hm.
Ooh.